[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos hablando de la viruela del
mono hasta la grabación de este programa
se habían confirmado más de 130 casos en
el mundo y se ha estudiado a otro
centenar como sospechoso pero contrario
al coi 19 no estamos hablando de una
enfermedad nueva es un virus que fue
descubierto en
1958 y el primer caso en humano se
reportó en un niño en república
democrática del congo en 1970 eso no
tico es decir que se transmite de
animales a humanos y una persona
contagiada puede contagiar a otras como
se contagia una persona de un animal
infectado mediante el contacto con
fluidos o mucosas de ese animal
principalmente roedores es decir si uno
de estos animales muerde a un humano o
si el humano inhala gotas respiratorias
el contagio -entre humano es similar al
entrar en contacto con los fluidos de
personas que hayan contraído la
enfermedad veamos lo que la organización
mundial de la salud ha explicado en los
últimos días ante el aumento de casos
guau iafas lo que clásicamente hemos
conocido como viruela del mono se
transmite por contacto cara a cara o
piel a piel es lo que sabemos hasta el
momento y por ahora no ha cambiado el
patrón de los casos que se están
presentando fuera de áfrica
en cannes y se observa forcarei now us
with mansion maquipo al ser una
enfermedad de contacto cercano el riesgo
para el público en general es bajo no
obstante aumenta cuando hay contacto con
una persona
made in fact según la ms las personas
que tienen la enfermedad son contagiosas
mientras tienen síntomas lo que ocurre
normalmente entre las primeras dos y
cuatro semanas y tanto las erupciones y
la saliva como las costras son
contagiosas asimismo el contacto con
ropa ropa de cama toallas u objetos
utilizados para comer pueden
desencadenar el contagio el virus
también se transmite de una mujer
embarazada al feto los síntomas incluyen
fiebre dolor de cabeza intenso dolores
musculares dolor de espalda poca energía
ganglios linfáticos inflamados y
erupciones o lesiones en la piel estas
pueden iniciar entre el primer y tercer
desde que comienza la fiebre estas
lesiones pueden ser planas o ligeramente
elevadas y contener líquido transparente
o amarillo para luego formar costras que
se secan y se caen
sow y no por lo que sabemos del virus y
de sus formas de transmisión el brote
aún puede ser contenido en saint therese
pero hay varios países en los que la
enfermedad es endémica república
centroafricana república democrática del
congo nigeria y camerún están reportando
casos en este momento y hay otros países
que han reportado casos en el pasado
hast no estudiaremos derecho exacto
mucho más y facsa los animales más
susceptibles a contagiar son roedores
ratas gigantes de cambia mirones pero de
la pradera web
esos son el tipo de animales de los que
puede haber un contagioso lotina
bélgica fue el primer país en decretar
21 días de cuarentena para los casos
confirmados de viruela o del mono por su
parte el centro europeo para el control
y prevención de enfermedades señala que
las mascotas de contagiados también
deben permanecer aisladas y ser
sometidas a prueba para evitar que se
inicien cadenas de transmisión entre
animales que lleguen a la fauna
silvestre la autoridad destaca que el
mayor riesgo se produce con los roedores
domésticos al tiempo indica que otras
mascotas pueden pasar la cuarentena en
casa si las condiciones no permiten por
otra parte las autoridades piden calma e
insisten en que la vacuna contra la
viruela como un protege en torno a un
85% contra la viruela del mono
cambiamos de tema y nos vamos hasta
españa donde un grupo de investigación
denominado ones y circular design está
reutilizando las conchas de los
mejillones que generalmente van a la
basura luego de consumir estos productos
del mar estos desechos se trituran hasta
obtener un polvo fino al que se le
agregan otros componentes para formar
una especie de pasta que sirve para
realizar impresiones 3 de
salud
nosotros como sociedad producimos una
gran cantidad de desechos relacionados
con el océano como mejillones conchas de
mejillón es así que con esto creamos
polvo y luego podemos transformarlo en
una especie de cerámicas we ride print
de spider with
lo que hacemos es imprimir esto en 3-d
luego podemos usarlo como una superficie
u objeto que es útil a los responsables
de la iniciativa partan de la idea que
los desperdicios no existirían si se
reutilizarán adecuadamente por ello
aseguran que lo que pasa es que existe
una falta de creatividad sobre cómo
desechar los materiales o componentes
que no nos sirven en su estado original
dos moléculas de esas son moléculas que
tienen otro precio y otro valor en
diferentes mercados así que tenemos otro
punto de vista sobre los materiales que
estamos creando imaginen que entre el 3
y el 7 por ciento del costo de cada
producto que compramos es el empaque y
lo tiramos de inmediato cada día
desechamos millones de materiales y creo
que esos materiales son la base de una
nueva industria las mismas días y debéis
ojani windows y nos despedimos con un
hecho simbólico pero que en la ciudad de
nueva york representa el fin de una era
fue desconectada y removida la última
cabina de teléfonos públicos de monedas
las llamadas para iphone wood
ubicada en la esquina de la séptima
avenida con calle 50 en el centro de la
gran manzana en nueva york' en el
momento de su auge what 35.000 cabinas a
lo largo y ancho de la ciudad ahora sólo
quedarán cuatro privadas para que claro
que que pueda seguir convirtiéndose en
superman en futuras películas así
concluimos este espacio les agradecemos
su sintonía y los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros en france24 france24
puntocom
[Música]
a